podcast special guest man go watch our
interview out right now we got Jay skis
in the building about to do what he does
new album it's out right now abolish
uncertainties go run it up let's get it
yeah
abolish some certainties man 324 you
know what it is man everything for weeds
froze up all my [__] back at the crib
all my ultra [__] you know how we do
this [__] first class to the plane crash
yes sir let me talk to him let me tell
you a story yo check I'm somebody I know
you heard of they call me B that shot
for burner I got a story I like to share
pertaining murder it all that started
while I was sitting in Target was on a
grocery list some [__] was instacarting
and threw me in with the eggs and the
almond milk I'm thinking finally I get
to see how the charger feel I never been
at a hundred percent but was ready to
connect my user with the connect of
fiends for metha maybe some fent feel
like I graduated I'm on a high my user
sipping activist while I get activated
finally got me a number started with a
7-1 natural was in the pocket with my
[__] while posted on Avenue I got a
couple games in my menu to show them
gratitude he said a record on snake
hires the altitude of cell towers and
sure and I got reception I kept it solid
and wanna be known for the
disconnections I heard while I was being
assembled users to throw you in the
garbage if you being a rebel so put them
cards too if you don't do it then listen
Bernie that song you recycle flip phone
gave me gems with a strong view I always
said if I get free about my package and
I never make my user feel you caught me
on accident we get home he threw me on
the charger on the cabinet next to the
baby's playpen next to the bassinet his
infant son is partially why he was
trapping hard life was difficult as
wrapping passion with a fractured jaw
I'm chilling charging this iPhone
sitting next to me calling saying it's a
problem that needed solving a couple
days ago I usually was talking about
upgrading to iPhone 11 because payments
was only 33 dollars a month they only
want the tax up front he hate me cause
my camera is sucks he was a seven with
the finger identification button [__]
was dope when it first came out but now
it wasn't with the facial recognition
cameras all in the 11 just as soon as
the mile he could trade him in and keep
it stepping so we suggested we set him
up via a text message he had a game plan
check out the method yo a day before he
was privy to a conversation in between
IUS and someone that matches occupation
over some Corners I use a Consolidated
for profit making he Preston told him
drop his location but show I usually was
getting money but Joe was never tough
disconnected from the call and hit some
chick to set him up and wanted to wet
him up but only had the one line he said
I'll get my burner and I'm grabbing my
nine and we'll call him just need you to
tell him your name is Autumn the Hutt
had always knew he was thirsty he'll
fall for it if you say you want to link
for a drink just get my burner and I'll
put a bullet right where he thinks the
iPhone said [__] that if you with it now
we write it as home I'll send a PIN to
his Ops and then I'm texting his phone
like pull up now listen burner all I
need you to do is not connect the
[__] call we can't be helping this
fool I get the processing y'all humans
will call it thinking like could I
really set him up leaving his family
grieving after he showed me love back in
my mind I know I'm Expendable I'll never
get a pat on my back for being
dependable and just as fast as I was
brought to life could be the end of you
what would you if you was me drop the
call and put it through whoa It's like
that you know what I mean right abolish
uncertainties man 324 everything for
ways man you know how we doing this [__]
man drum work [__] first class to the
plane crash you know that I gotta run
that whole thing back because I think I
caught on there what was going on
oh [__] oh [__] that's what we doing
Jace Keys appreciate you brother you all
ready you already know me yes sir hey I
know you just watched a new freestyle
guess what we're dropping them every
week sometimes more than once a week
Jesus we've been dropping a lot lately
uh shout out to LRG don't forget go to
l-r-g.com use the promo code bootleg
save 30 off at checkout you get this
look at this jacket look at that lining
it's LRG baby 30 off this bad boy go to
l-r-g.com promo code bootleg and save 30
off at checkout and check out another
freestyle next week